JOHN RAE-GRANT: Hi,
I'm John Rae-Grant,
product manager for
Gmail Extensibility.
I'm here to talk about
the new Gmail API.
Let's start with a
quick history lesson.
Back in the midst of the
distant past, there was email.
Many email systems
were closed, meaning
that you had to use a
specific application
or a specific website
to manage your mail.
This made it hard for people
who had multiple accounts
or multiple clients
to manage their mail.
So IMAP was born.
IMAP is a standard protocol
designed for an email client
to connect to an email server.
IMAP's great, because
it means that we
can do cool things like get
all of our mail into one inbox
or send email using any of our
accounts from the same client.
So IMAP was designed to
enable a full-fledged email
client to connect
to an email service.
Gmail initially introduced
IMAP support in 2007,
specifically with
the goal of making
it easy to use mobile device
email apps to access your Gmail
account.
And it was good.
Then things got interesting.
Once Gmail opened up to
IMAP, the developer community
realized there was now
a way to enable users
to add features that
used their Gmail data.
These developers,
you folks, went way
beyond building
simple email clients.
You did brilliant things, like
adding a record of messages
exchanged with each
prospect to a CRM system.
You made useful utilities, which
manage your email subscriptions
or allow you to send
mail at a later date.
You even wrote custom
Chrome extensions
which talk to IMAP and
extend the Gmail UI.
All of these are good things.
So what's the problem with IMAP?
Well, IMAP's great,
but Gmail and you
have gone way beyond
what it was designed for.
IMAP was designed
a long time ago.
Originally, in 1986, with
the last major core protocol
version in 1998.
To give some context, that's the
year the Sony PlayStation was
battling it out
with the Nintendo
64 and a new search engine
called Google first launched.
APIs have come a
long way since then.
IMAP was designed to handle the
kind of mailboxes people used
to have.
It was never intended to
scale to hundreds of thousands
of messages in an inbox.
In 2004, Gmail
revolutionized the inbox
by giving you one
gigabyte of storage,
giving you the ability to stop
wasting time sorting folders
and instead use powerful
queries to search labels.
Despite the decade since
IMAP was introduced,
it still doesn't have
standards to support
the revolutionary way
Gmail interacted with users
a decade ago, let alone our
many improvements since then.
It's not that IMAP isn't useful.
It's that it's getting used
in ways for which it wasn't
designed, sort of
like this golf club.
You can use it for
bowling, and since you're
clever and determined you might
manage to knock down some pins,
but it's not really
the right tool.
So we're introducing
the new Gmail API
to enable you all to
creatively meet the modern use
cases of today's users.
We've kept in mind
all the performance
and ease of use that you'd
expect to come with that.
The new Gmail API
provides very simply
what you would expect, with
RESTful access to threads,
messages, and labels,
including drafts.
In contrast to IMAP,
which requires access
to all of the user's
messages for all operations,
the new API gives fine grained
control to the user's mailbox.
If you just need to send mail
as a convenience from your app,
you don't need to ask the user
for permission to read mail.
To keep in sync, the API allows
you to query the inbox change
history, thereby avoiding the
need to pull or do archaeology
to figure out what changed.
Most importantly,
this API is designed
to make it easy and efficient
to do specific queries,
such as get me all the
messages exchanged with Joe.
Or get all the messages received
with the my_company label.
Or get me all the
messages in this thread.
Essentially, the API
offers the full search
capabilities of the web
UI using the same syntax
as the search box.
Since the new Gmail API
is a standard Google API,
you get simple HTTPS
access using RESTful calls
and get your responses in
JSON, XML, or Google Protobuf
formats.
You can also make these calls
from standard web languages
like Java and Python.
And there's no need
for a TCP socket.
This means that the API is
accessible from many cloud
environments that
couldn't support IMAP.
Not only does the
new API replace
IMAP for many
applications, it also
replaces SMTP for mail sending.
And one huge advantage is speed.
As I mentioned
earlier, IMAP was never
designed to do what you've
been getting it to do.
Because the new Gmail API
was designed for the Gmail
backend architecture,
it understands
labels instead of
folders and is optimized
for exactly these operations.
Here are some
preliminary speed tests
which demonstrate that even
before the tuning, which
you beta users will
be helping us to do,
the Gmail API handles
getting a thread
or doing a search
for matching messages
a factor of three to 10
times faster than IMAP.
Since the new Gmail API is a
standard Google Developer API,
you'll be able to get
started right away using
the same developer key
and developer console
that you already use
for other Google APIs.
All access is under standard
OAuth 2.0 authentication,
so you've likely already
done that as well.
If you haven't, the example
apps and SDK documentation
have done most of
the work for you.
The Gmail API is entering beta
the week of June 24, 2014.
We're really eager to get
your suggestions and feedback.
To get started, go to the
Google Developers site
and follow the instructions
to sign up for the beta.
And we'd love to hear your
feedback and suggestions.
On behalf of the Gmail team,
thanks for your attention.
And we can't wait
to see what you'll
make with the new Gmail API.